now you can see what i'm going to do
i've by the way i've rubbed off my lines
which i know
you might not want to do as you go just
so you can see it more clearly because
it gets pretty
busy with all these lines flying around
so 15.4
is going to be here right
okay now what you'll notice is
especially if you have done this like on
your piece of paper and you know
your lead pencil or whatever you're
using it has width right so as you go
across
i think most of you will find that it's
somewhere in between here and here
right do you see that now if i go all
the way down to the bottom
it's five to six okay that's that's the
numbers i'm reading at the bottom
now just pause for a moment before i
answer the question
what should i actually say if you're
between five
and six then
if you ask someone who's like five years
and say
11 months old if you ask how old are you
what would you answer
i would say okay so at that very small
age you might do it in half or quarters
or whatever but just generally speaking
you'd say i'm five
right i haven't turned six yet you're
not six until you've passed
right over six so everyone in here in
this space here
they're all what we would call five
years old okay so therefore my answer
what age group is the median bmi equal
to 15.4
is um five-year-olds i think that's the
answer
okay all right
let's keep going part d boys are
considered to be obese if their bmi is
greater than the 95th percentile for
their
age okay now by the way this is such a
better way of doing things um thinking
about percentiles because as
time progresses and as culture changes
um the numbers themselves will also
change
right like everyone here is way taller
than they were 100 years ago because we
have better nutrition and
hygiene all that kind of thing so
where's the 95th percentile
for 19 year olds have a look have a look
you might need to draw yourself a
vertical line that's what i'm going to
do
yep
okay so when i draw my vertical line up
from age 19
and i get in closer for a better view
you can see
here's um here's 30. let me put it in as
a separate color for you
here's 30 and oops i'm a bit i'm a bit
wonky
yeah um 30 would go straight across
there
and if you go five units down that's
where 29 is
right so where does my point land up
here
there point i'd probably say it's
closest to i'll get my point out of the
way now
uh it's cl oops sorry uh it's up to
about
29.8 i think that's the closest okay
you've got limits of reading here if it
was really close and you're like uh
point six point eight um that would be
okay you still read the thing properly
okay and it was down to accuracy so i
would say
a bmi above 29.8 that means you're above
the 95th percentile
right okay let's talk about this
nine-year-old his bmi
is 21.5 is he considered
obese according to this chart so i'm
gonna look for his age
his bmi and see where where he's rated
okay so let's have a look
nine years old nine years old
so here's my vertical line up from nine
years old
okay and when i look for where 21.5 is
that's halfway between 21 and 22.
so yeah that's right you can see as i
draw that across to me
there he is right there okay so is he
above the 95th percentile
it's up yes so according to this chart
they would classify him as
obese okay um they're going to ask the
same thing
for part e but in reverse they're
looking for underweight
so rather than looking above a certain
line we're looking below
right yeah you and me both are here so
you can see
what's the bmi below which four-year-old
boys
are considered underweight so five
percent is the
it's the lowest curvy line right
yeah unfortunately that's that's not how
old we are so um you can see
it looks like it's right there do you
see it
okay yeah that's right it looks pretty
much bang on 14. so if you've got a bmi
below 14
that would be classified as underweight
a 13 year old boy has a bmi of 15.8 he
underwent let's go across to 13 years
old
draw up your vertical line
and what bmi am i looking for again 15.8
and he looks okay what um if you were
looking at this
and had to make an estimation what would
you say his percentile is what do you
reckon
yeah it's between ten and five between
five and ten it's sort of a little more
towards the ten
so it's like an eight or a nine or
something like that eighth or ninth
percentile
roughly okay
um okay uh we're on the home stretch
part f the bmi of boys is considered to
be normal if it's between
5th and 85th percentiles so then it asks
about 17 year old boys
okay this seems relevant
thank you okay so we're looking for 17
so i'm going to draw my vertical line
from 17.
this is the part where all the guys grow
up
so you can see i'm actually not going to
draw the whole line
i'm just going to draw the part that's
relevant to this question right so you
can see
i've gone from the bottom curving line
the fifth percentile that guy
all the way up to the 85th one and
what's outside that is irrelevant to me
so can you read across to the left-hand
side what
range would you describe what's the
lowest and what's the highest
yeah i think 17.6 is pretty much bang on
all the way up to
25 exactly
i'd probably say 24.8 is closest
is closest right um so
25 is close but i think our graph gives
us more accuracy than that
last one interquartile range so you need
to remember a few things here
quartiles right the interquartile range
is between q1
and q3 now this graph doesn't tell you
which ones they are you have to remember
which percentile is which so where's q1
25 it's gonna be 25 right so you may
like to write on the right hand side
here
25 is q1 50 that's the median
q2 and then of course q3 is
75. so you got your upper and lower
quartiles now
so what age group are we interested in
now
age eight so you're gonna have to come
over to the left hand side
and you wanna follow it looks like um
the fourth line from the top
the third line from the bottom for eight
year olds
right
okay so i think this is what we're
getting
right now remember it's asking for an
interquartile range so they don't want
you to tell them
what the quartiles are they want to know
the
the difference between those that's the
range in the quartiles so i need to take
the top one
subtract the bottom one it looks like 17
take away
how do you read it yeah i think 14.8 is
pretty much bang on
so therefore the difference between
those is the inter quartile
range make sense can you can you guys
okay so interquartile range is only
between the 25th percentile
and the 75th percentile because they're
quartiles right
so the placentals include the quartiles
in them you just gotta know which one
yeah okay okay
yes
yeah that's a great question um and it's
a really good
question to ask i need the ages
you can see the graph starts high and
then it comes down low now remember i
said
the higher the numbers are the kind of
the
higher proportion of like fat height
that kind of thing but then it dips down
why is it dipping down what would make
think about this
what would make a bmi get lower
yeah think about this right remember i i
didn't i didn't write it up here again
bmi is weight
over height squared remember that now i
think we're presuming that under normal
circumstances these people are not
malnourished
so it's a lot of their weight is
decreasing but their height
it shoots up right so can we go exactly
right in proportion here
this has a bit of a growth spurt right
so this sort of drops down
okay and then as you go to the right why
do you think it continues going up
yeah that's right so and that's because
like sort of puny happens around here
so they start to get muscle mass well
some people start small
i don't know what happened with that but
anyways